[Music]
loudly
you're loudly playing owen benjamin
videos on your phone well you're sitting
at the bar
yeah like the cool songs like how they
rule you
remember that one remember how they roll
you
i just by the way i'm so happy i just
ruined royce's day you guys watched his
day be ruined in real time
somebody did a cover of it somebody
coddington
no somebody else oh my god another
person
just rising up to uh owen benjamin's
challenge to cover this
wonderful um version of the song i
apologize for me eyes i look like
butthole eyes i apologize for me graves
disease
and people seeing it as possible
but you don't care too much for free i'm
sorry but can anyone sing
yeah the woman who privated a video
there's nobody we found nobody that can
sing
or speak today it goes like
they this your wrist it ain't cool but
that is how
they roll oh my god is he really this is
how they rule you dude remember that uh
m bear race bear i can't listen to this
song without
crying then you need to [ __ ] honestly
you got to go see a mental health
professional and i don't recommend that
[ __ ]
it's just a nothing but a racket for the
sis unless olivia soprano says but um
if you can't hear this song without
crying
you're extremely unstable emotionally
there's nothing worse than like more
cringe than people referencing
crying in youtube video comments or like
like it's just whenever somebody's like
oh my god
i can't even watch this without crying
it's like okay then you are
unstable that's should never be a
problem especially if you're a guy
should never be a problem
[Music]
little pitchy dog you're a little pitchy
there dawg
apollo in the chat i cry too please make
it private
how many covers of this are there
and also this isn't a writ people are
like saying how they rule you
like it's an owen benjamin original all
he did was change the lyrics to
hallelujah and
it's not even his song what a subversive
little thing to do like
you do a basically like a
what is how they rule you it's an
unfunny parody song right
yeah it's a seri it's a serious
parody song which is like weird
and then like and then people just play
it and then it like spreads around and
people like
yeah that owen benjamin song and it's
like no that's hallelujah or whatever
but what about shredder bear dude
[Music]
i did not know there were 500 covers of
this
[Music]
a better singer than the other one
chris cornell over here but this is what
bothers me is this guy almost seems like
kind of like he could be normal
i i didn't know jungle boy was a fan of
uh owen benjamin
jungle boy r.i.p luke perry